thomas bonjour alors gérald darmanin
donc en collant chair la procédure de
dissolution du groupe génération
identitaire une annonce qui intervient
un mois après une action à du
groupuscule dans les pyrénées est déjà à
l'époque le ministre de l'intérieur
était monté au créneau oui gérald
darmanin s'était dit scandalisé par
cette action des militants s'étaient
rendus à la frontière franco espagnole
pour s'opposer à l'entrée de migrants
sur le territoire français une opération
qui ressemble à une autre menée en 2018
dans les alpes et pour laquelle trois
membres de génération identitaires
avaient été poursuivis poursuivi avant
finalement d'être relaxé en appel au
mois de décembre dernier ce qui leur
était reproché était notamment de créer
une sorte de confusion car leur présence
pouvait être assimilée à celle des
forces de l'ordre alors pour ce qui
concerne la dernière action en date dans
les pyrénées une enquête préliminaire a
été ouverte une décision motivée selon
le procureur de saint gaudens part je
cite des propos tenus sur une banderole
très clairement anti immigration et
surtout la raison pour laquelle cette
banderole a été déployée l' enquête a
donc été ouverte pour provocation
publique à la haine raciale et qu'elles
sont peu mal et en revendication
principale de ce groupuscule
régulièrement dans le viseur des
autorités génération identitaire a fait
de la lutte contre l'immigration
illégale et l'islamisme ses deux
principaux combats sur leur site ils
appellent à la jeunesse à la
mobilisation et se présente comme la
première ligne de résistance leurs
opérations sont souvent d'ordre
symbolique et reprennent les codes de
l'agit-prop mode d'action popularisé
notamment par les ong greenpeace
leur volonté est d'attirer l'attention
de l'opinion publique sur certaines
thématiques
outre leurs actions aux frontières
génération identitaire s'est fait
connaître en 2012 en investissant le
chantier d'une mosquée à poitiers ou
encore plus récemment lors d'une
manifestation à paris contre les
violences policières organisée par le
collectif la vérité pour adama
les militants avaient alors déployé
depuis un toit de paris une banderole
sur laquelle on pouvait lire justice
pour les victimes du racisme anti blanc
et comment a été accueilli cette annonce
de la dissolution du groupe
c'était une décision qui était très
réclamé qui était réclamée depuis
longtemps en tout cas par des
organisations politiques
aussi hâtive qui voyait une forme
d'injustice par rapport à la dissolution
d'autres associations telles que le ccf
par exemple alors des élus et des
représentants politiques se sont
toutefois insurgés de cette décision
c'est le cas de florian philippot ou
encore du rassemblement national qui
dénonce je cite une atteinte aux
libertés fondamentales certains y voient
une stratégie politique puisque cette
dissolution intervient en plein débat
contre sur la loi contre le séparatisme
et alors que gérald darmanin est accusé
notamment par la gauche de faire le jeu
du rassemblement national surtout après
le débat télévisé entre le ministre de
l'intérieur et marine le pen jeudi
dernier à noter enfin que des militants
de génération identitaires ont décidé de
se mobiliser pour contester cette
dissolution
une manifestation est prévue samedi
prochain dans la capitale
merci beaucoup thomas pour toutes ces
précisions